while people in Houston are also looking
to another leader former mayor bill
white white spoke with our Jamie yuccas
about the lessons he's learned from the
Hurricanes that impacted Houston while
he was mayor from 2004 to 2010 he
welcomed the vacuous after Hurricane
Katrina and made critical decisions
during hurricanes Rita and Ike well this
week he became one of Harvey's victims
when his own home was flooded the former
mayor had to wade through waist-deep
water to leave Jamie yuccas is in the
center of Houston Jamie good morning
good morning Hurricane Katrina was
devastating because it impacted
low-income communities but here in
Houston Harvey impacted everyone across
the economic spectrum in fact this
bridge I'm standing on was once
underwater and the water that runs below
it right now flowed through Bill White's
house he though actually says that he's
thankful because so many people in his
community are coming forward to help
when you watch it play out were you like
oh my gosh I thought this would always
be a worst-case scenario well this was a
little worse than the worst-case former
Houston Mayor Bill White battled several
hurricanes during his tenure he built
his house 18 years ago along the Buffalo
Bayou and took extra precautions knowing
a major hurricane could flood his
backyard but he never imagined it would
flood his home and put it on stilts oh
if we had a 1 in 500 year flood they
would go underneath and not into the
house it not only came up to the deck
but inside the first floor of his home
you heard gurgling noises and rumbling
noises underneath the floorboard and
then I looked down and saw spouts of
water coming up from every electrical
circuit every small crack neighbors
snapped this photo when he finally
decided to leave his house by wading
through waist-deep water now he has
contractors ripping up walls and trying
to remove insulation before mold sets in
12 years ago it was white helping others
rebuild their lives he invited Katrina
victims to relocate from New Orleans to
Houston
he said come on into the city you know
the policy of the city which I announced
on the first day was
pretty simple first doing to others as
you'd have them do unto us we're best
when we help each other out as members
of the same team
when Hurricane Rita headed for Texas
just weeks after Katrina hit mayor
whites at an evacuation plan in motion
but people panicked and fled in mass
causing gridlock more than a hundred
people died on the road from accidents
and heatstroke
the current houston mayor has pointed to
that incident as one of the reasons he
did not evacuate for harvey is there
times that the city may just be too big
for this type of network it is so big
that it makes evacuations decisions
difficult do you think we've learned
from each natural disaster or are they
all still kind of the same I hope we
learn I mean the fact of the matter is
we tend to learn and then we tend to
forget we do know this that each of us
hadn't had control and then we are in
control of is how we respond to
adversity is our resilience our attitude
the example we said for others white
says once the water fully recedes he
expects much of Houston to be able to be
rebuilt he did invite us back one year
from now and he says at that point he
hopes we see a strong and resilient
community Maurice okay Jamie yuccas
thank you